- My name is Bradley A. Fanner,
I'm a private investigator
from Modesto, California.
- I'm Investigator Maki Kudaka,
I specialize in criminal
defense and surveillance.
- I'm Investigator Tim Helton
from Tim Helton Investigations.
I never played Clue as a kid
and this is gonna be a unique opportunity.
(door creaking)
(woman screams)
(old fashioned mystery music)
(footsteps)
- I say what better way to show
who the world's greatest investigator
is than a friendly game of Clue.
(suspenseful sound effects)
(dice rolling)
I want to suggest that this
crime was committed in the study
by Mrs. White, with the lead pipe.
(Maki laughs)
- I suggest it was in the
kitchen by Mrs. Peacock
with the candlestick.
- I'm gonna make a suggestion
that it is Miss Scarlet,
in the kitchen
with a wrench.
- You should be taking good notes, Maki.
- I always take good notes, Bradley.
- It's an investigator's
most important tool.
- Clue should have DNA these days,
some fingerprints and--
(Bradley laughs)
- Weren't there any surveillance cameras
in any of these rooms?
- The crime was committed
by Colonel Mustard.
- In the hall.
- With the lead pipe.
- Damn it.
I think you're ready to--
- Make an accusation?
- [Maki] Do it.
- An accusation?
- Don't pressure me.
- I think it was done in the ballroom
by Colonel Mustard
with a wrench.
Sounds like you're MO to me.
I just did some great
process of elimination
that you guys didn't see.
- I think this crime was committed
by Colonel Mustard
- With a knife.
This is getting tense.
Can't we ping everybody's cellphone?
(Maki laughs)
- Like real ready?
- See where they were at?
Why are you looking at my--
- Trying to get some clues here.
(Bradley laughs)
- He's trying to intimidate
you with his looks.
- You need to obtain
that information legally.
- Is there a limit to how many suggestions
you can make before you have to--
- That's the key to
solving a murder though,
is asking a lot of questions, right?
- When I was a much younger guy,
I got set up.
They pretended my training
officer got killed with a pipe.
- How many murders have you seen committed
with a candlestick, in your career?
- None.
- None?
- I wonder why there isn't
a character in this game
that's trying to feed us false information
and throw us off.
(All laughing)
Investigators, I'm ready
to make an accusation.
(thunder)
I believe this murder was
committed by Colonel Mustard
with the lead pipe, in the library.
- [Maki] Are you out?
- I'm out.
- Alright, investigators.
I think I'm ready to make an accusation.
(thunder)
I believe it was Colonel Mustard,
in the ballroom, with a lead pipe.
Ballroom.
Mustard.
Lead pipe.
(thunder and screaming)
(laughs) And I win.
- I'm really upset because
I know Tim cheated.
- My excellent investigative skills
had no bearing on this game, whatsoever.
- There's a mirror right behind me,
and I know he's looking
through the reflection.
And go figure, he murdered me, too.
- I mean, if this was real life,
my reputation just went out the window.
- I feel pretty good about it.
I'm gonna miss Brad.
I'm sorry, I just met Maki today,
but that's the way things go.
(old fashioned mystery music)
(elevator music)
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm.
Hmm.
You don't know the half of it.
(elevator music)